the challengers are gonna be bigger than
he's ever faced before spider-man has a
rich history of having great stories the
core of our story is this duality
between being Peter Parker and being
spider-man what's cool about mr.
negative is that he also has a duality
he's got his positive side as Martin Lee
who runs the homeless shelters in the
city but he also has his negative side
when Peter makes the connection that the
leader of the inner demons is the guy
who my aunt works for we got the perfect
collision of those two worlds
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new spider-man to talk about
between infinity war and spider-man ps4
so I'll try to distinguish between the
two because there's a whole bunch of
iron spider infinity war stuff that
they're dropping the last couple of days
and we just found out when we're getting
the spider-man game along with a whole
bunch of details about that so we are
hitting peak spider-man and that's to
say nothing of what's gonna happen next
year with another spider-man Avengers
film with Avengers 4 and then the next
spider-man Home Coming movie whatever
that's called spider-man 2 something so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos when we get a little bit
closer to the game actually coming out
its in September like the title card
says I'll do a giveaway for the actual
video game but until then it's the
Infinity Gauntlet that I've been doing
the giveaway for so let's start with the
Infinity war stuff first then I'll talk
about ps4 stuff so you actually look at
this his suit looks almost the same
texture is Iron Man suit so a lot of
people now are like wait a minute
does he have the cool nanites that Iron
Man has to it's totally possible but the
idea I think you know when he's in the
trailer hanging on to this ship here is
that he doesn't know anything about the
suit he thinks he's gonna die he's just
trying to be a hero gets himself in over
his head just like he did during the
homecoming movie I was trying to be just
like you mr. stark and then Tony just
takes off after him like you can see the
nanites form this giant ass cannon that
gives him a boost that's way bigger than
his normal repulsors remember because
spider-man's suit is Iron Man tech he's
hacked into it at all times so if
spider-man got his ass handed to him or
something bad was about to happen
Iron Man would be the first person to
know about it he takes off after him and
probably has something to do with either
putting the new suit on him somehow
or like physically attaching something
to him that the suit comes out of a lot
of you've also asked me hand-in-hand
with that like if Iron Man just like
gives people new tech and everything new
comes out of whatever it is that he
gives them is the same thing true of war
machines new suit does it come out of
that leg harness that he uses to walk
around like a normal person
the thing about Iron Man tech is like
you go all the way back to Civil War
even the older films he has that little
watch that turns into a mini hand cannon
wouldn't it make sense that he bill
his friend something's special that
enables him to walk like a normal human
being
puts his name on it not because he's an
[ __ ]
and he just likes to brand everything
with the Starck name but because it's
special stark tech that does a lot of
extra things so just look at some of the
textures on this war machine so this is
hardcore but he's war machine so of
course this suits gonna look more
hardcore than Iron Man's Iron Man's is
gonna be more hardcore it's just that
you can't tell because there's all
nanite bleeding edge technology in this
actually just does look like the spider
suit is closer to the war machine
functionality than it is to Iron Man's
but remember this is Spider Man his
suits are more form-fitting so
anything's possible but it's all the
same basic technology it's just that the
new stuff the brand-new stuff Iron Man
tinker's around with he saves for
himself but you look at some of these
plates here obviously there's more armor
it's designed to function in the vacuum
of space which is why he needs it when
he's up on the ship in outer orbit you
see that the new upgraded gauntlets look
like they have projectiles that either
stick out or they're like blades now
because a lot of it's made to mimic
different properties of different
animals and in the comics when he
actually like physically became a spider
he could actually shoot little
projectiles out is almost like
poison-tipped darts that might be what
these are or they could just be straight
up blades that come out remember that
anything that the other stark suit had
like the AI functioned with Karen suit
lady inside of it this suit will have a
better version of that so I'm guessing
that it's still suit lady and it can
probably reconfigure these gauntlets to
do whatever he needs so they also
probably shoot webbing in addition to
more hardcore things like blades or
poison-tipped darts anything that a
spider would be able to do the suit will
replicate that function but let me know
in the comments which part of the suit
do you actually think that everything
else comes out of like all these
serrated plates like the chest it feels
like there's just some small piece that
attaches to him maybe around his waist
or something like that but everything
else comes out of because it's not like
he climbs into something like this it
looks way too hardcore for that the
really cool thing about this spider-man
trailer other than finding out that the
game is actually coming in September so
we'll be playing it later this year is
the mystery suits that they're teasing
so what I'm guessing
is is that one of these is probably
either the iron spider or one of the
most classic hyped-up suits like it'll
be a symbiote future foundation
something in that vein just like one of
the biggest suits that he's ever worn
and there's really just like a handful
of those there's many many spiderman
suits like the bag head suit that would
actually be a pretty cool easter egg but
when you're really talking about the
hardcore spiderman suits you're really
thinking iron spider stuff that actually
integrates a little bit with the movie
even though i'm guessing that whatever
they do for iron spider within this game
will look closer to the comics than the
MCU because they're already redesigning
his costume to look a little bit
different from the movie costume so it
makes sense that they double down on
comic book Easter eggs with their DLC
the second Spidey suit that they're
revealing in July is probably just the
next one they don't do after that like
it'll be symbiote something really crazy
but let me know in the comments what do
you think these two mystery suits are
going to be and if you didn't know about
the game Miles Morales will be playable
there's gonna be a bunch of side quests
but they're all tied to the backpacks
that he webs up around the city so
within the game they'll just be many
many backpacks webbed up all over the
city for you to go find and do side
quests but obviously main quest mr-
we'll send Fisk stuff going on Mary Jane
is a big character so the game is much
more like their Batman Arkham treatment
of the spider-man character only it's
all for comic book stuff so if the
Batman Arkham game sort of pulled from
all over the place I wouldn't be
surprised if some of the DLC integrated
some larger MCU stuff but for the most
part the game seems like it's grounded
in the comics for those of you that are
asking the Spider Man of this game is
supposed to be about 23 years old
they say he's piqued spider-man at the
peak of his abilities so you have to
imagine that when we get to the next
spider-man movie Tom Holland will be
about 17 years old not quite a senior in
high school so he still got a couple
years to go a lot of speculation about
who's gonna leave the Avengers team if
Tony Stark ends up dying during the next
two Avengers films I do think that he's
mentoring spider-man to become a better
leader someday but even in a couple
years spider-man will still be the baby
of the team so it'll probably be one of
the more adult a list characters like
Captain Marvel or black panther black
panther is kind of busy though ruling
his nation and there
gonna have two sequels of that movie
anyway so if any of the Avengers are
gonna be really busy in the next couple
of years it's gonna be Black Panther so
I wouldn't be surprised that they picked
somebody you didn't expect like even
Black Widow would be a candidate to lead
the Avengers because it doesn't
necessarily need to be the most powerful
member like Black Canary led the Justice
League in the comics for a little while
it just needs to be a member that's good
at being an administrator so that you
can tell your most powerful members
where you need them the most but a lot
of that's all speculation I wouldn't
worry too much about that there was even
a new rumor about them doing an eternals
movie during phase four but that got
shot down there's gonna be a lot of
rumors flying around now that they've
hit their press doer but let me know in
the comments what kind of spider-man
videos you want me to do and videos for
the video game obviously I don't do a
lot of gameplay videos but there's still
a lot of stuff going on so while you
wait for everything click here for brand
new infinity war and click here for
brand new Deadpool thank you so much for
watching everybody to stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight